you wouldn't think it'd take very much
to convince someone to direct the latest
installment in the hugely successful
batman film franchise but as it turns
out there was one huge reason matt
reeves didn't want to take the job keep
watching to find out what it was
and
here we
go the latest reboot featuring dc comics
famed caped crusader the batman is
hitting theaters worldwide finally
completing a monumental task undertaken
by writer director matt reeves the
batman of course has undergone different
iterations during its arduous production
cycle which began with filmmaker zack
snyder's batman choice ben affleck not
only starring in the title role but also
writing and directing the film when
affleck left his batman project behind
over personal reasons the film's studio
warner brothers had to figure out who
could take charge of the project next
fostered by celebrated filmmaker j.j
abrams on the writer director's wb
series felicity matt reeves film
breakthrough came at the helm of the
abrams produced found footage monster
movie cloverfield the doors of
opportunity swung wide open for reeves
after the success of that film which
earned 172 million dollars at the
worldwide box office against a 25
million dollar budget this landed the
filmmaker such high-profile gigs as 20th
century films rise of the planet of the
ape sequels dawn of the planet of the
apes and war for the planet of the apes
in 2014 and 2017 respectively suddenly
reeves was calling his own shots as both
writer and director of the last two
films in the apes trilogy which was
clearly the right move for the studio to
make seeing how the entire trilogy is
widely considered one of the best in
modern cinema it also gave reeves the
kind of showbiz juice to make demands on
future projects that other filmmakers
might not get to make in a new interview
with the new york times reeves said he
was in post-production on war for the
planet of the apes when warner brothers
asked him to direct affleck's version of
the batman and while reeves told the
outlet that the iteration of the tale
was quote a totally valid and cool take
on the dark knight it just wasn't the
right story for him to direct he said i
just didn't know how i would direct that
oh take it easy sweetheart that's right
instead of following in the footsteps of
such revered batman directors tim burton
christopher nolan and snyder reeves put
the studio on ice declining to shoot the
script they'd sent him he recalled to
the times i don't think you're going to
want me because i wouldn't do this and
then they asked me what i would do i
said i'm in the middle of making this
apes movie so i can't really tell you
after finishing war for the planet of
the apes however reeves came back to
warner brothers with the one condition
he needed to direct the film he needed
to write his own original script the
writer director pitched his ideas for
the batman and began writing the
screenplay in 2017 after five years and
various pandemic induced production and
release delays the batman starring
robert pattinson as batman and zoe
kravitz as catwoman opened in theaters
in march of 2022 it's clear from the
interviews he's given that matt reeves
has the utmost respect for the character
and mythos of batman he didn't want to
just go in and make any old batman movie
he wanted to create a definitive dark
knight story for a new generation as he
went on to tell the times that involved
taking a novel approach to the caped
crusader i wanted to fight against any
sense that batman would remain static i
wanted the stakes of the story to
challenge him in a way that shook him to
his core he has to change to accomplish
that reeves had to go darker than any
live-action feature-length batman had
gone before as reeves told time magazine
i wanted to play on this idea that
batman is going to unleash on these guys
and there's a part of you that can't
wait to see it but reeves didn't want
the same old fight scenes in his film he
wanted to go bigger and darker as he
went on to explain you go to a batman
movie to see that moment and then you
see it's having a toxic effect it makes
you get a little unsettled
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]